alors cette même technologie la
pornographie à rester virtuel on est
encore qu'à ses prémices et elle devrait
nous dit-on révolutionner le genre
regardez et vous me direz messieurs
mesdames
et vous qui nous regarder ce que vous en
pensez merci c'est un pas en haut mais
filmée à la première personne c'est à
dire que france baissent les yeux je
vois le bas de mon corps dans le bas du
corps de l'acteur en l'occurrence et
donc ça donne réellement l'impression
que je suis en train de faire ce qu'il
est en train de faire en l'occurrence la
lamoura à une dame à dos dames à trois
dames ou là
[Musique]
l'expérience est pour le moins réaliste
oh
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez y à
49% des français qui envisagent le sexe
en réalité virtuelle dans dix ans c'est
à dire qu'il se dise voilà ça sera
important
j'étais très déçu en voyant ce reportage
pourquoi ensuite parce que les équipes
là de martin veille quotidien ils sont à
la masse ah bon en 2019 parler de ça
j'ai essayé au moins cinq ans c'est déjà
chez nous c'est déjà par tous égaux vous
avez fait ce test là avec cet appareil
en réalité virtuelle de pornographie en
3d vers quoi on voit la vie on voit des
cheveux la plus incroyable impression
quand soudain vous revenez d'un rêve
éveillé mais tout à fait je peux vous en
parler encore avec des tremblements
c'était il ya cinq ans imaginez c'est
enfin pas procuré mais qu'est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas chez fiera les kurdes mais
qu'est ce qui est différent de deux
dindes un porno dote d'un film
pornographique tradis très bonne
question en effet ça procure des
émotions ça émoustille parce qu'on voit
là comme je disais la vraie vie en face
on voit des femmes qui arrivent à côté
de vous carrément et qui vous aiment les
émotions transmises par ce film sont
colossales par rapport à la réalité d'un
pauvre film en 2d et là on se sent dans
une ambiance mais incroyable est-ce que
c'est pas un peu triste de l'elysée
d'être heureuse salon sourire
[Rires]
oui mais on n'est pas censé non plus
remplacer totalement l'acte sexuel avec
vaches charnel avec deux personnes
d'accord maintenant c'est vrai que pour
une fois j'ai l'impression que la
technologie est au service
voilà du contenu ça me semble
complètement logique que la 3d
investissent cet univers sexuelle
pornographiques et tard parce que c'est
quoi ça m'étonne salon après c'est selon
c'est vrai que c'est un tout mais ça
fait un peu ce qu'on aurait aimé
attendait parce que vous n'êtes pas au
bout de vos surprises c'est parce que
parce que pourquoi les gens vont aller
vers aussi ce genre de pratique c'est
que il va y avoir bientôt des sextoys
connectés écoutez bien des sex toys
connectés qui n'était a marre de
synchroniser les scènes du film avec le
mouvement du corps et d'être encore en
immersion gouvernait ce que vous avez un
peu moins beau c'est long c'est en soi
un onglet qu'on a reçu tout à l'heure
sur l'économie que ce sujet non non mais
free peut-être sur l'économie ne faut
pas laisser faire et donc ça existe déjà
ça va là c'est en train d'arriver à ça
va être ça va être à la portée de toutes
les bourses d'accord pas mal pas mal que
vous appelez alors en revanche
effectivement est ce que on pourrait
dire parce que là on est sur un mode un
petit peu ludique mais il ya des gens
qui connaissent malheureusement une
forme de misère sexuelle qui n'ont pas
de partenaire qui peut-être irait voir
des prostituées
on parle des problèmes aussi de la
prostitution est ce que ça ne résoudrait
pas ce problème là je ne sais pas bien
sûr d'autant plus si on allait les
outils dont palau par caroline moi c'est
pour ça que j'aime bien ce système à
l'averse de mes camarades c'est que je
pense à ces gens qui n'ont pas de
compagne ou compagnon et qui s'accélère
un peu plus déprimant que d'être devant
sa télé et n'y a rien qui se passe en
fait tous d'accord et la voiture que
c'est un peu moins déprimant mais
simplement d un peu au moins interagit
en bougies et tout ça enfin moi j'ai
bien essayé pour le coup parce que je le
tenais mais c'est vrai j'ai avec moi je
vais t'emmener au affiche alors vous
savez où il aimait bien sûr je vous la
ramène demain en plateau si vous voulez
nom veut ça va aller en fait mais c'est
pas gentil on peut pas demander alors
mais visiblement vous êtes à la pointe
de la technologie saab est là toujours
j'adore le high tech dit mais qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de cette pornographie
en réalité virtuelle côté madame benhaim
quand ai dit madame bédard tant que j'ai
bien senti cette carte quand vous êtes
venu me chercher la sortie m'avait dit
que vous avez besoin d'un petit peu deux
halls vais pas le niveau mais que les
besoins d'une finesse d'analysé en
aparté je pense depuis le début de
l'émission et les missions se porte
mieux dès ce mois ci
je suis prêt à vous accompagner la
saison prochaine bien ça ne savais pas
qu'on m'attendait sur ce genre de sujet
vous savez vous savez c'est eros et
thanatos c'est la vie on parle de la
ville si on parle de l'amour on parle de
la mort l'amour ce parti de la vie alors
je vais donner un point de vue je suis
d'accord avec vous avez raison pour la
misère sexuelle peut être hélas
j'enfonce peut-être j'ai choqué des gens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais l'esprit très mal place mais pas
du tout c'est parce que je vous regarde
non mais c'est vrai pour la misère si
[Applaudissements]
vous avez progressé aussi d'ailleurs à
mes côtés il avance comme au tennis ça
oui vous de jouer avec nadal votre sens
de la répartie et nettement est
nettement plus important maintenant on
peut se poser la question
non mais parce qu'ils voulaient mais qui
tentera d'aller chercher c'est ce que je
voulais dire quoi laisser tomber
[Applaudissements]
cependant en réalité virtuelle c'est
tonton ou bien ce n'est pas intéressant
vous nous avez dit que c'était très
intéressant également remercié le
chiffre est bien à 69 ils sont joueurs
de téléspectateurs et je vous dis bravo
les cinquièmes chronique à l attention
lorsque vous utilisez un casque de
réalité virtuelle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]